let's do one more fairly involved
example of adding or in this case
actually subtracting rational
expressions so let's say I have 4 over
9x squared 9x squared - 49 and from that
I want to subtract I want to subtract me
be able to do this in a different color
I want to subtract 1 over 1 over 3x
squared plus 5x minus 28 so just like we
saw in the last video we want to find
the least common multiple of these two
expressions and the way to figure out
that is to factor these two things now
this first expression you might
recognize as a difference of squares
it's 3 this is 3x squared minus 7
squared so we can rewrite it as 4 over
over 3x well let me write it this way 3x
plus 7 times 3x minus 7 right 3x squared
is 9x squared 7 squared is 49 difference
of squares and from that we're going to
subtract this thing over here let's see
how we can factor that out well once
again this has a non-one coefficient
here so you can always use Pythagorean
theorem but that actually gets messy if
you actually just want to factor as
opposed to getting roots so the best
thing here is to do grouping so let me
factor it over here I need to find two
numbers I need to find let me just write
it over here so we have 3 X let me write
it I want to write it someplace where I
can watch all right here so I have 3x
squared plus 5x minus 28 I need to find
two numbers that when I multiply them I
get 3 times negative 28 negative 28 so
it's negative 60 and negative 24 that's
negative 84 if I multiply those two
numbers and a plus B should be equal to
a plus B should be equal to 5 so what
numbers well this is 7 and 12 is that
New York Times your times table 7 times
12 is 84 so if you make this a 12
and you make this a negative seven then
it works 12 minus seven is five 12 times
negative 7 is 84 so I can rewrite this
as 3x squared
I'll group the 12 with 3 because they
have a common factor of 3 so plus 12x
minus 7x minus 28 and once again 7 and
28 have a common factor so it's looking
good and just to reiterate I just all I
did is I rewrote this 5x as 12x minus 7x
these are obviously the same thing 12x
minus 7x is 5x
but then we can group them we can group
them just like that so if we factor out
a 3x here this first expression is the
same thing as 3x times X plus 4 and then
in the second expression over here I'll
do it in red or in white I guess let's
factor out a negative 7 so minus 7 times
X plus 4 and lucky for us we have a
common factor as X plus 4 so we can
factor that out so if you factor out the
X plus 4 you get X plus 4 times 3x minus
7 times 3x minus 7 so that's what this
guy over here will factor into so I can
rewrite it right here so this expression
is the exact same thing as 1 over 1 over
well I could write the 3x minus 7 first
a 3x minus 7 times X plus 4 this and
this is the exact same statement so
let's figure out what our common
denominator is here so let's figure out
what our common denominator is so our
common denominator write it like that
and you still have all the factors of
this guy right here so it needs to have
a 3x plus 7 it needs to have a 3x minus
7 and also has to have all of the
factors of this guy well it already it
already has a 3x minus 7 so it already
this is already done
it doesn't have an X plus four in it yet
so now you have to multiply it by X plus
four so clearly if you look at this this
is clearly divisible by this guy because
it has the same all of its factors you
could divide this out and it's clearly
divisible by this guy 3x minus 7 times X
plus four 3x minus 7 times X plus four
so this is the least common multiple of
these two expressions now how do we get
how do we get so what do we have to
multiply this guy by to have this as the
denominator well I just have to multiply
the numerator in the denominator by X
plus 4 so if I multiply this guy let me
scroll to the left a little bit by X
plus 4 by X plus 4 over X plus 4 my
denominator will work out and so my
numerator will become 4 times X plus 4
which is 4x plus 16 that's this first
term over here and then what do I have
to multiply this guy by to have the same
denominator is this well I have a 3x
minus 7 times X plus 4 3x minus 7 times
X plus 4 I have to multiply it by 3x
plus 7 I have to multiply it by 3x plus
7 so I also have to multiply the
numerator by 3x plus 7 so this is 4x
plus 16 minus 1 times 3x plus 7 or minus
3x plus 7 is the same thing as minus 3x
minus 7 just distributing in the
negative sign and then what is this
going to be equal to the numerator we
have a 4x minus a 3x 4x minus of 3x will
just be an X and then we have a 16 minus
a 7 which is a 9 and then in the
denominator we of course have all of
this stuff over here which is 3x plus 7
times 3x minus 7 times X plus 4 and
we're done